one of the big focuses I've had in my
work has been trying to get out of the
idea that there's such a thing as a
dystopia or a utopia because of the fact
that my book has slavery in it the
robots are indentured until they're 10
and as a result of that lawyer clever
corporate lawyers have figured out a way
to make humans indentured as well
because of course robots are human
equivalent so if robots are human
equivalent why not have some human
slavery - that's great but it's
indenture it's freely entered into it's
not really like slavery it's actually
kind of nice right because somebody pays
for your meals you get to have a house
so you can see why people would love
that idea so so that's very dystopian
the idea of reinventing slavery in the
in the 21st century but at the same time
the book is full of this incredible
green technology sustainable technology
people are dealing really well with
trying to conserve and and preserve the
environment so it's a little dystopian
it's a little utopia it's just topia and
I think as you know as we think about
science in the context of stories and in
the context of these kinds of world
building maps it's important to remember
that as we move into the future we're
not really heading toward a world where
things tend toward getting better and
better and better by some person's
definition of better and better or
really worse and worse we're always in
these middle phases where some things
are getting better for some people some
things are getting worse for some people
the reality is that even if we you know
achieve some kind of goal like safe
universal health care for all there's
going to be another problem that comes
up so we're never gonna reach a point
where like you know we're become
light-filled beings and beam out of
existence like in Star Trek there's
always going to be these problems that
come up and I think science sometimes
makes the mistake those of us working in
science or technology of thinking but
it's getting better and better and
better and better and like everybody's
just gonna be fine it's like nope
there's always going to be new problems
and we need to think about what those
problems are gonna be brand-new awesome
problems
[Music]